my beautiful favorite molly did and she
yeah she made this little thing she's
like oh don't worry because we couldn't
find purple boots look we made little
little booties we're having will sasso
using all of the data i have absorbed
from text messages and emails between
you and the astonishing friends you grew
up with i was able to recreate your
childhood diary you must now read the
passages i have selected in the voice of
stone cold steve austin
this is stone cold steve austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary begin
yeah it made you do this last time too
when you were in the crow makeup it made
you do a stone cold that's right
holy [ __ ] okay so there you go yeah
that's one yeah that's something that
doozy
likes and things that we should be doing
i guess so yeah all right well you know
if uh yeah so this is stone cold i love
doing these these are fun doozy's come
up with these things that are not from
my life
but the way an ai is interpreted my life
but they're kind of like it some of the
stuff funny style
all right man
are you um
hey by the way are you stoned right now
yeah you want to smoke a little more
weed
uh sure
we're just gonna take a break to smoke a
little more weed we don't even have to
take a break we can continue going as we
smoke
all right
hold on a second dude
we're just taking a little puff
did doozy say we have to finish these by
the by the end of the show or
set as a reward for
i think for you
dressing as your dress and uh for us
saying good night yeah well i've soared
with the eagles and slithered with the
snakes been everywhere in between yeah
i'm gonna tell you something right now
you gotta do the right
impersonation yeah you can't just take
whatever impersonation you wanna do oh
god dig it
this is stonecorp dude i'm really i'm
really [ __ ] high real quick just let
me get a little more weed yeah man
indulge in
dudes these guests
need doomsies
okay
oh hell yeah
all right
uh april 8th 1991 dear diary well it's
official the funniest guy in ladder just
became
the luck
[Laughter]
well it's official the funniest guy in
ladner just became the luckiest guy
dealt the senior secondary that's what
we call the high schools yeah
um
i woke up this morning just like any
other day brushed my teeth did my hair
pinched off exactly three and five
eighths inches of brown gold to make
room for breakfast
but when i came down the stairs to eat
said breakfast both my parents told me
that they were gonna take my little
brothers to visit our aunt tasman and
uncle gourd
i'm italian i don't have people with
those names in my family so that's
gonna chris and i don't have younger
brothers yeah i have two older siblings
gonna chris in the new gonna cr uh gonna
crest in the new pool they got for
summer but tasman and gord are all the
way out in chilliwack
awesome
that's two hours two and a half with
traffic so they're gonna stay the night
which means
i got the whole [ __ ] house to
myself
which means
no one will be here to stop me
which means
i could do whatever i want
which means
it's time to [ __ ] party
that's pretty you're gonna throw a house
party yeah okay come in
april 9th 1991 dear diary i'm batting a
thousand every every person i invited is
rsvp'd with a resounding yes
gibber prevallia timothy bubble
rachel crustation
jessamine
[Laughter]
jessamine tenders
greg kincade geno dolphin dante little
egg bethany protein
d'andra towel
jennifer neutrino
tabitha mordred
steven [ __ ] trello by it because you
can't have a party without [ __ ]
trillo
lament the lamp
hell even cornelian squeen said he'd
come by you know we had our differences
in the past but we put those behind us
and become close friends the universe
truly moves in mysterious ways
so we got a couple of new additions i
think to the weird world of your your
junior high in there a couple of new
people yep
april 10th 1991 scored scored the drinks
but not but i got no place in my house
to hide 200 cans of bottles without my
parents wondering why i got so thirsty
all of a sudden luckily geno dolphin's
dad has an old tool shed in their
backyard that he never goes in anymore
so we got the drinks in there on ice for
the next three days and no one's the
wiser except maybe gino's older brother
mark who keeps his victorious secret
catalogs in that shed oh man but now
that i got the beverage situation locked
and loaded
it's time to come up with some
activities for my guests i was thinking
arm wrestle leg wrestle singing contest
football game [ __ ] and blame standing
bench press
happy meals tractor wheels sleeping
upside down
[Applause]
gold hats baseball hat bats
gold hats baseball bats screaming in my
crown
putt-putt pizza hut
eat charcoal briquettes
thin noodles
thick poodles living with tourettes
hear a lie start to cry someone's gonna
die
these are
party activities break a law draw a
straw feed yourself a pie
gitch gaunch pinch launch
gobble dandy do
no gobble don d
it's
crank tank thank bank you'll have to
wait and see
that's that is that diary
that was that log in the diary
[ __ ] christ
oh there's more hey you want to smoke
more pot no i'm good
april 11th 1991 dear diary i haven't
been completely honest with you yeah i
want to throw a party to prove i'm the
coolest kid in ladner but it's more than
that
the real reason i want to put together
the best event this town has ever seen
is to impress somebody and i think you
know who it is
rachel crustacean
[Music]
i like her and i think she likes me but
we still haven't had that first kiss so
i'm hoping that the moment will be right
at the party and to help create the
perfect moment i wrote her a poem
i don't know and to make sure she knows
how much she means to me i went down to
the antique paper maker and got a
special scroll of papyrus 2 000 years
old
then i wrecked an antique
gator bone quill set and a victorian
inkbot
i read a few books about calligraphy
you're going all out on this [ __ ]
poem oh god i read a few books about
calligraphy and did my best to make it
look it make it look nice
and it looks real [ __ ] nice so she
should enjoy it as she's reading along
to me reciting to her from memory
here's a poem
i can't please
i felt love but once before
a man who's dead forever
but talk of him i shall not do
tonight i speak of loving you
on second thought let me just say
one real quick thing if that's okay
so big so strong so powerful
rewrote that
what was allowable
21 bouts undefeated the streak is what
we all needed
just who was this number breaker
he went by
the undertaker
the streak did not exist in 1991 as a
matter of fact it was his first match at
wrestlemania wrestlemania seven versus
jimmy snuka is when it started that's
when the streak started and then at
wrestlemania 30 in 2014 against uh
brock lesnar this the streak ended
okay interesting so he's he's in my head
dudes he is
a little man he's got dude in his name
yeah it's got dude in its name right
yeah so it
the ai is like taking all times from the
undertaker's life and putting them into
1991. pretty weird
never be another like him a hero but
he's dark and grim he's in my dreams and
in my heart
he doesn't wrestle he makes art
if i should die before i wake
my soul is his to undertake
through hell
will walk hand in his hand
love everlasting for this man
one fateful day so long ago something
happened in his first show
undertaker took me over
dick so hard i lost composure
she's gonna [ __ ] love it
that's the poem he's gonna [ __ ] tell
the rachel cruz station it ends with
things so hard let's go april 9 1991
dear diary it was a disaster crustacean
showed up two hours late and when she
finally came she wasn't alone she
brought tandy baggins
tandy baggins was not invited to this
party for a reason me and tandy had heat
well there's you know
heat dude yeah yeah brother yep
we went to business together in the
third grade selling candy out of our
backpacks at lunch we sold out every day
for a few months
then tandy got sloppy instead of keeping
the operation mobile he just sat down
opened his backpack at a table in the
middle of the cafeteria and started
selling there was a circle of 20 kids
standing around him within two minutes
couldn't have drawn more attention if he
had fireworks coming out of his ass
he got caught and he got scared they
wanted the name of his accomplice in
exchange for leniency so he sold me out
he only got a week in detention they
called my parents who were
understandably not happy
i kept my distance all night didn't want
to make a scene and baggins never left
crustacean side so i never got my shot
fate can be cruel
i'm not letting this discourage me
tandy's got a round of bad karma coming
his way for ratting me out
hell i can feel it
shoot i might even cause it oh [ __ ]
oh man pretty good
that's interesting there's a new
character in that one
thank you moving on tandy
please tell a baggins and brave and
great
if you'd like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
then